olaf scholz für dich der gewinner des
jahres
wurde das urlaub stolz für mich der
gewinner ist tatsächlich und keiner hat
erwartet denn das ist die größte
geschichte für mich 2021 der wahlerfolg
von urlaubsländern uns im frühjahr 20 21
in diesem jahr am 2 leute in berlin noch
an wahlerfolg von urlaubsorts geglaubt
dass eine weise in engste berater
wolfgang schmidt und das andere war olaf
scholz selbst kein anderer auch der
sogenannten politischen
großkopf hat die mine talkshows
rumsitzen so wie wir heute haben haben
irgendetwas auf olaf scholz gegeben das
lag daran dass die spd zementiert war
über jahre hinweg bei 15 bis 16 prozent
und das änderte sich auch erstmal nicht
als urlaubsland kanzlerkandidat wurde
aber er hat seinen stiefel durchgezogen
beinhart klar er hat natürlich auch wenn
darüber gesprochen von den gegnern für
den fehlern seines gegners profitiert er
hat von der zerstrittenheit zwischen
markus söder und armin laschet
profitiert und hatte die klaren
botschaften mindestlohn 12 eur stabile
renten und eben das mit respekt das
waren seine klaren sachen an die sich
auch eben jeder erinnern konnte und
deswegen hatte am wahlabend 25,7 prozent
geholt mehr man glaubt es gar nicht als
die spd hatte seit 2005 aber am
wichtigsten war dass olaf scholz die
unterstützung von saskia esken hatte die
er ja bekämpft dathe und gehen auch im
kampf um den parteivorsitz der spd und
saskia esken hat ihre persönlichen
eitelkeiten
rachegelüste hintenan gestellt und
gesagt okay ich als parteivorsitzender
stifter scholz war er hat die besten
voraussetzungen um tatsächlich kanzler
zu werden insofern ist saskia esken im
wesentlichen mit verantwortlich für den
wahlsieg von olaf scholz und ich glaube
irgendwann wird sie das auch einfordern
die frage mich nur band und wie aber
fürs erste muss man vor allen dingen
sagen wurde vor allem eins belohnt der
kampfeswille von olaf scholz und es
zeigt wenn die lage noch so düster ist
wozu man in der lage ist dann kann man
alles schaffen sogar kanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland in
auswegloser lage zu werden er bilde ich
kann erstmal natürlich verstehen dass
die olaf scholz als den sieger des
jahres gekürt hat ich habe ja lange zeit
überhaupt nicht geglaubt dass er kanzler
wird ich möchte mich auch bei den
zuschauern von 48 entschuldigen wer also
irgendeine gesagt hat also nina schenk
hat befehl nachgesagt nachgesagt er wird
es eh nicht tut mir sehr leid ich habe
mich sehr getäuscht ich werde niemals
mehr eine wette abgeben wenn der
deutliche politik aber ich muss dir
sagen ich sehe einen ganz anderen sieger
noch und der ist für mich glaube ich
vielleicht sogar der heimliche sieger
und das ist lars klingbeil weil das muss
man ja ganz klar sagen ich würde mich zu
der vermutung hinreißen lassen keine
aussage dass ohne lars klingbeil olaf
scholz auch nicht so erfolgreich gewesen
wäre dementsprechend würde ich saskia
esken weil da weiß ich nicht so ganz was
hier zu dem erfolg groß beigetragen hat
würde ich ein lars klingbeil austauschen
und dann bela großes wunder in der
weihnachtssendung sind wir einer meinung
ich finde die sprache ich finde in dem
zusammenhang um eine gegenposition mal
wieder einzunehmen aber damals habe ich
vorausgesagt dass olaf scholz kanzler
werden könnte
ich möchte mich entschuldigen
nein scherz beiseite ich finde er konnte
doch nur gewinnen weil die cdu so
verdammt schlecht war also das muss man
doch mal ehrlich sagen 25% du hast das
recht das ist das beste ergebnis
allerdings wir erinnern uns dass den
fast wert ein gewisser peer steinbrück
im jahr 2013 erreicht hatte war auch
schon mal bei 25 prozent aber er hat nie
darüber jemand geredet dass in
irgendeiner form kanzler werden könnte
weil die kanzlerin weil fast 40 gelandet
ist damals also zumindest weit über 30
also die cdu war so grottenschlecht in
diesem wahlkampf das selbst eine
delegierte spd von der man niemals
gedacht hätte dass sie ein ziel kommen
beschaffen konnte und das ist ja auch
etwas wo man sich so ein bisschen und
wir politischen beobachter ja auch
belegt also heute dachte ich als ich den
friedrich merz da so gesehen habe na ja
was wäre gewesen wenn der armin laschet
nicht bei der flut gelacht hätte ein
prozent mehr bekommen hätte dann wäre
kanzler und wenn alle sagen schlechtes
ergebnis aber cdu und natürlich hat er
stolz das nicht geschafft ein
ganz ganz wichtiger punkt eigentlich die
cdu hatte alles jahr in der tasche ja
ich meine sie hatte eine eine koalition
quasi fertig und vor vier jahren die
jeder politische beobachter in berlin
seit 2005 eigentlich will nämlich
jamaika oder wollte jetzt ist es auch
vorbei
sie lag auf den sie hatten die grünen
die wollten unbedingt das war ja erst
mit mühlen dass die dann zu spd darüber
gegangen sind sie hat die fdp die
sowieso wollte im grunde aber sie hat
das alles in den sand gesetzt und
insofern muss man sagen schuld cdu aber
so zehn prozentpunkte die holst du auch
nicht in dem du einfach nichts tust du
musst schon dann was derzeit stolz
gemacht und man muss dazu sagen die spd
hat einfach die fehler die die anderen
parteien gemacht hat nicht gemacht die
spd die einzige partei der drei kanzler
kandidaten die wirklich ihren kandidaten
nicht nach dem beliebtesten in der
partei aufgestellt hat sondern geschaut
hat wer kommt bei der breiten masse am
besten an das haben die grünen nicht
gemacht sie hatten ihr internes system
mit frau hat vor recht und die cdu hat
sich ist voll auf risiko gegangen oder
dieser bvdm csu kandidaten nehmen nehmen
wir unseren kandidaten der bringt es
auch noch irgendwie nach hause auch wenn
er unbeliebter ist und man muss dazu
sagen was k s ging gemacht sagt kersten
ist ihm zumindest nicht den rücken
gefallen die hätte genauso den markus
söder spielen können in rot und da ist
lars klingbeil ein toller wahlkampf
gelungen und der spd als partei da einig
zu sein eine partei die er in den
letzten jahren nicht für einigkeit
bekannt war also das ist auch in bayern
keiner großen wahlerfolge jetzt gefeiert
also ich bin mir wirklich nicht sicher
ich weiß es sagen immer alle mit markus
söder wäre es anders ausgegangen nein
bin ich mir geistig aber ich sage nur
saskia esken hat nicht das gemacht was
markus söder mit armin lauer gemacht
hätte sie machen kann was ich an einen
punkt dabei finde wenn man über den
siegeszug von olaf scholz spricht dann
redet man ja oder olaf scholz zumindest
nicht von vier jahren sondern die
kalkulieren mindestens acht jahre du
guckst geschossen
es ist hier zuschauen über mich das wäre
weil ich für mich stolz so langweilig
finde und das ich finde das interesse
offenbar im schlafwagen ins kanzleramt
gefahren weil wie du sagst die cdu so
unterirdisch
eine interessante frage wer wird denn
dann in den nächsten jahren wirklich
sein widersacher kann das friedrich merz
schaffen muss er dafür fraktionschef
werden und was macht mag da wird der
darauf dringen dass diesmal die
kanzlerkandidatur in seine richtung also
ich rechne tatsächliche zugegeben
voraussage dass die cdu wirklich eine
eine lange regina zu generation wie berg
die keine fremdwörter aussprechen ihr
habt das habt ihr erst mitbekommen kann
verrät real nicht ausbrechen und
gemein ist es gemeinsam aber nein ich
glaube ich glaube die die cdu muss ich
jetzt schaffe ich das wort regenerieren
sie braucht eine lange
regenerationsphasen wer kann scholz wer
kann scholz paroli bieten wir sind aber
bei der bahre zeit niemand auf die
absehbare zeit ich glaube dass ich
glaube auch dass das im märz so ein g 1
1 gezeigt wird von der von einer
geist toten cdu dass sie auf absehbare
zeit bis die jungs wie kaya und hier
waren nicht gerne sieht aber ist ja
super werbung war heute auch hoch ich
bin mir wirklich sicher dass das märz zu
einem widersacher in den nächsten vier
jahren werden kann wenn er das profil
auch aufbaut und auch mit den ganzen
jungen um sich herum die ihn großartig
finden die union muss doch jetzt kämpfen
sie wird kämpfen das ist scholz
geheimnisvoll dabei die nachfrage ist
doch noch nicht mal entschieden
innerhalb der cdu wer ist denn überhaupt
die oppositionsführer im bundestag werde
antworteten also pro haus wird auch
genannt
werden und das ist natürlich offen das
geheimnis von scholz ist der
unerschütterliche glaube an sich selbst
ein gutes kleines team um sich herum das
ist ja nicht wirklich groß und dass er
tatsächlich kontinuität symbolisiert
aber vor allen dingen
professionalität aber das ist etwas was
die deutschen geschätzt haben sie
wussten was sie an ihm haben und
deswegen haben sie die stimmung und ich
glaube der größte widersacher von olaf
scholz wird keine personen sondern es
ist die ampel es ist zum ersten mal eine
dreier-koalition es sind zum ersten mal
drei wirklich unterschiedliche parteien
mit verschiedenen klientel sven die
nicht bedient werden und wenn olaf
scholz es nicht schafft diese regierung
jetzt über vier jahre auf
zusammenzuhalten
dann ist das sein größtes problem und
das sich stärker als irgendwelche
personen im bundestag was glaubst du
alex wenn die kanzlerin in diesen
stunden und auch dann friedrich merz
dort gesehen hat und der sie konnte ja
immer besonders gut mit olaf scholz
glaubst du sie hat sie also ein bisschen
gefreut dass olaf scholz kanzler
geworden dass stellen sich armin laschet
selbstverständlich selbst verstecken
kann gefreut
hat dass auch sie ich habe das hier an
der stelle auch schon gesagt die angela
merkel hat sich schon im rahmen ihrer
kanzlerschaft davon verabschiedet
eigentlich in die cdu kanzlerin zu sein
du hattest dann auch gesagt dass
wahrscheinlich bezeichnet das große
kanzler aus dass sie irgendwann ihre
partei hinter sich lassen
überparteiliche kanzler werden das war
bei helmut schmidt so das war bei
gerhard schröder so und auch bei angela
merkel hat doch gestern hat doch kein
wahlkampf immer im letzten moment hat
sie dann im bundestag war das sehr
interessant alle reden darüber dass das
schaut sie jetzt kopieren sie schuldig
und und da ging es dann ja um diese
begriff ich glaube hat erbschleicherei
genannt die raute all das was olaf
scholz versucht hat zu kopieren naja du
glaubst du er kann merkel kopieren und
wirklich ein langer kanzler bleiben in
deutschland ich glaube chance es wird
als hängt natürlich jetzt wirklich wie
du sagst von der von der stabilität
dieser ist schon wieder gelungen
entflammt wort zu sagen ich hab ich aber
fremd wolle
man muss man muss
frau bock sitzt mit drin zu seinen
geistigen
nein ich glaube dass ich glaube dass
wenn diese stabilität dieser koalition
die wenn die gewährleistet ist was wenig
was wir nicht wissen wir wissen nicht
was da für stolpersteine noch auf sie
zukommen dann ist eigentlich stolz
prädestiniert für eine lange
kanzlerschaft weil nämlich nicht weil er
so brillant ist oder weil die ampel so
brillant ist sondern weil die weil die
cdu jahre brauchen wird um sich zu
regenerieren und das ist wie bei ich
glaube ich habe so lange in england
gelebt dass ich mal mit den englischen
beispiel im kopf habe das ist wie bei
fetscher nach fetscher war erstmal
totenstille bei den tories und dann
brauchst du jahre bis dann ein ganz
junger konnten das wird dass das war
dann cameron der plötzlich bei einem
parteitag aufgegeben ist eine predigt
den kannte niemand der ist hat eine
brille eine rede gehalten und plötzlich
ging das herz auf der konservativen
endlich haben wir jemanden zu dem wir
aufschauen können das wird die cdu noch
vor sich haben märz ist nicht diese
figur ist nicht mehr regulär aus dem
aufkommen wir haben jetzt entweder der
cdu jetzt vor uns figuren wie john major
die einfach versuchen diese komplett
desolate partei wieder auf die beine zu
stellen und irgendwann wird ein junger
kommen aus der generation charles aus
der generation co waren und dann das die
partei wieder wach küssen aber jetzt
wird sich jetzt liegt sie erstmal im
tief kromer